今日はこちらしているカップです
そうですね今の世の中は大変ですねこれをなブルース
エラー
あの床にまあ奥でやメーカーまあ体でまぁ
アメリカほどじゃないんだけどもまぁヨーロッパ特に英国
いたりスペインドイツなかなか酷いですね
日本の事情文やヨーロッパとかほくでよりもいいですけれども
なんか新聞で見るとえ
その北海道なんかではまたそういうあの心のビルスの患者がまた増えてきたとかね
だからこの問題は多分相当の間には続くと思いますよね悪くなったり良くなったり
ソロその影響の一つはやはりできるだけそのい人間が前ほど動かないことに家に特に私
の年齢の人たちが家に残ってくださいとか
あの互いにちょっと距離を維持してくださいとか
もちろん航空会社が非常にいまー
スケーキじゃないでしょもう生き残れるかどうかという問題ですよね
だからその中でじゃあその言葉の勉強はどういうに対してどういう影響が出るかという
こと僕ちょっと考えてたんだけども
一つはね今の世の中はですねー
今までは
その人間ともの物流が盛んに覚えてましたよね色んなものが中国で生産されたりとか
日本で生産されたりとかカナダから原材料
ダーマー位中国やいろんなところへまた輸出されたりとか
ん
その場合によってはその他の国のいわゆる原材料が
中国語 a 輸出されてそこで格好してまた入手されたりとか
だからそれに関連したそのビジネスマンが飛行機に乗ってあちこち行って会議もして
それが多分これから稚児
少なくなるんですよねもっとこの
まあ生産が分刺されるんじゃないかエマー cd プリントアウトもありますし
そして今の特にその頃なぁ
関係のいろんなまあ
まあ防具って言うんですかます家だとかいろんなですうものの shelly さんが
やはりいうニューに頼ってたら非常にまた起源だと
だから戦略的にもっとたくさんのものが自分の国で生産しないといけないと
それじゃあ他の製品もそういう風になるかどうかはちょっと疑問ですよねたぶん
時間経つとまた同じように安い所へ有利なところから輸入することになるんじゃないか
たが貿易また
少しは減るけれどもまあ復活するんだ
口腔病がもっと時間かかるけれどもまあ
まぁ今までほどじゃないけども
普及賦活するんじゃないかと思うんですけれども
しかし一つ今のコロナウイルスの一つの原種僕にとって非常に印象深い現象はですね
国際協力国際連帯
そのバックシーンのその
発見というか
それは zune 世界的に色んな国が研究データいろんなデータお互いにその
シェアしたりして情報もした利益は良いそのシェアしてですね
空前な国際協力の上でその新しいその薬品とか
その
全世界の
人口をどうやって防衛するかとそれが全世界的な
まああの動きが今我々があの
まあ表れてきているわけですよです僕の感じはですね
そのものをとか物流もの人間が動く
その
まあ
集中と方がですね in 動画ですね
やや少なくなるしかしアイディア
アイディアがもっと坂に交換されるんじゃないかと思うんですよ
このコロナウイルスに対して我々全部のどの国の人でもですね
同じ船に乗っていますだから仮にじゃあ日本でそのコロナビールさが0になったとし
ますかあるいは今ニュージーランドでゼロになったとされているわけですけれども
しかし人間が一人でもですね
そのウイルスの持ってる人が日本に行ったり
ニュージーランドへ行ったりまあ恐れ焼けよか
どこか系英國併用がそれまた出る可能性があるんですよ
だからあるいはこれからですねアフィかかそういう国でですね
その黒ナビですがまた資産
もっと韓国大するのであればやはりそこからもまた
うん
もどって来る可能性もありますからだがそれが一つの終わり全人類
全世界の問題であるだから全世界的な
その
あれですよ解決方法もう共同で見つからないといけない
だからそういう風にですね色んなアイディアが盛んに
動くその今までは自分の事務所で選んだものを考えて自分の同じ会社の人達といろいろ
考えて遠いやりましょうかと
しかし今はその頃ナビ留守の時に家にある岩離れて仕事する
離れて仕事するのであればコンピュータ通じて
仕事するんであればそれは同じ会社の人間とその
ずんならズームを通じていろんな話をしてあるいはお客さんとか供給先とその
コンピュータ通じて
近いピア自分も厨二ていろんな話をするのであればやはり世界どこでも
だから自分
黒じゃなくてどことでもいろんな話いろんなアイディアの交換ができるようになるわけ
ですよ
そうなるとやはり言葉というのが大事になってくる
今まではその自分が動ける範囲の人間とそのコンタクが一番大川多かったわけですよね
日本人が日本の電車に乗ってその日本人の事務所に入って
ラジ日本人の会社の社員といろんな話をしたりしてお客さんのところへも
って場合によっては輸出すっかいうニューするけれどもほとんどそういう自分が動ける
範囲内のコンタクが一番多かったんですけども僕はこれからね混ぜます
そういう自分が会える人じゃなくて
そのインターネットを通じて今宅のとれる人間といろんなまあ
今とか今単にが増えてくるんじゃないですかで教育も受賞なんですよ
あの
なーん
もちろん我はリンクやってるでしょウイーンというのはまあインターネットでのその
言葉の勉強の一つの機能を持ってはですよね
だから別に学校行かなくてもそのインターネットを通じて勉強できるわけですよ
インターネットでいろんな勉強その
内容勉強の
教材もダウンロードして使えるわけですよ
だからその物理的その e 5の教室か
学校とかそういうものからやや独立される傾向にあるわけですよ
だからそのいろんなその世界のいろんな国の人とコンタクト取ったり
巻雲情報を交換したりするのもそういうニーズが増えてくる
それと同時にそれじゃあ外国語英語で
わけじゃなくて a 前北米の人が日本語を勉強したり中国を勉強したり
ドイツ語を勉強したり勝利へがですねニーズも増えてくるし
そしてそれをあの
どこでも勉強できるようなその
まああの
環境も今宿しているわけです
だから一つのマボがこれからのパターンとしてやはり
a クローナ b です8
終わっても
その貿易のパターンエイサーの情報交換協力国際連帯その辺のパターンが変わってくる
でその
勝利常緑ねガーン
なんかそのいわゆる独自で何も考えるんじゃなくてもっと国際的にそういうお互いに
もう助け合うという気持ちでこれから進まないといけないと
それにはやはり言葉というのは大事ですそれだけ僕いろいろ今朝
考えてたことをちょっとジャパ欄にいいいいたかたわけですよ
が今日は共有こういうことですあそれでリンクのライフストリームはね今で英語でその
life p 6でリンクの融通がその我々とまぁ参加してどういう風にしてメンバー
がリンコロその
言葉を勉強するためにどういう風に使ってますか
そのいろいろ面白いないほどから youtube かどっかでどういうふうに
取り入れるというか
a
法に導入しているかっていうのがね
英語で今で6回花回もやってはいるんだけども
ロシア語で一同もやりましたから今回はですねもうスペイン語や日本語や他の言葉
ドイツ語でもねポルトガル語でも
やりたいと思ってますからもしあの
興味のある方がいればぜひあの連絡てくださいそれじゃあ
さよならー